موضوع العنصريه اللي واجه اللاعب
البرازيلي فينيسيوس خلال مباراه فريق ريال
مدريد مع فالنسيا ضمن الدوري الاسباني
واليوم صارت في المزيد من التطورات الازمه
تحولت لازمه دوليه وتطورت اكثر واكثر
وشفنا فيها دول بترد ورئيس بيهاجم ونوادي
بتدعم فعلى المستوى الرسمي في البرازيل
كان في تحركات اولها كان من الرئيس
البرازيلي لولدي سيلفا اللي اعلن دعمه
وتضامنه مع فينيسيوس
تجاره ريال مدريد
الثانيه
اما وزاره الخارجيه البرازيليه فاستدعت
السفير الاسباني عشان تحقق في اللي صار مع
فينيسيوس وكنوع من التضامن اختتمت
البرازيل يومها اللي اعلنت فيه تضامنها مع
فينيسيوس باطفاء ضوء تمثال المسيح
الايقوني في ريو دينيرو لمده ساعه كامله
وفي اسبانيا لقب فينيسيوس دعم كمان فنشر
رئيس مجلس الوزراء الاسباني بيدرسون
تغريديجل فيها انه لا يمكن ان يكون هناك
تسامح مع العنصريه في كره القدم ومجلس
الرياضه الاسباني اصدر بيان جير في انه
راح يراجع او يرجع يشوف لقطات من المباراه
لاستدعاء اي شخص من مرتكبي الواقعه للمثول
امام الادعاءات هذه التطورات على المستوى
الرسمي والسياسي اما المستوى الرياضي فكان
في سيل من الادانات للي صار مع فينيسيوس
ونبدا من رئيس الاتحاد الدولي لكره القدم
جياني انفنتينو اللي اعلن دعمه لفينيسيوس
وقال انه الف يفا بتوقف جنب كل لاعب يتعرض
لنفس الموقف ونشر خطوات عمليه للتخلص من
هذه الظاهره خلال مباريات كره القدم اما
رئيس الاتحاد الاسباني لويس روباليس اعترف
انه كره القدم الاسبانيه بتعاني من مشكله
العنصريه واعلنت دعم لفينيسيوس
مره
وعلى فكره هو ما اكتفى بس بدعم فينيسيوس
لا كمان فاجا الكل بطلبه من رئيس الاتحاد
البرازيلي لكره القدم انه يتجاهل السلوك
غير المسؤول لرئيس الدوري الاسباني
ارد على فينيسيوس على تويتر ووصف اللي
عملوا بالتباهي على الشبكات الاجتماعيه
طبعا رئيس رابطه الدوري الاسباني كان رد
على فينيسيوس على تويتر وقال له انه
الرابطه بتعمل اللازم ضد العنصريه ولكن
الرابطه كانت اعلنت مؤخرا انها فتحت تحقيق
في الواقعه ومحاسبه المتورطين فيها انادي
فالنسياوس اللي من وقت الحان تو اسمه ضمن
حمله تضامن ودعم واسعه من نجوم ورياضيين
وانديه
اما بخصوص البيت الداخلي لنادي ريال مدريد
اللي فينيسيوس من ضمن لاعبي فكان لرئيسه
فلورنتينو لقاء مع فينيسيوسفي مقر الفريق
الملكي واظهر خلاله دعم او دعم ريال مدريد
الكامل لفينيسيوس اما النادي فيكنلو بيان
رسمي شكر في كل اللي وقف الى جانب اللاعب
من شخصيات رسميه وغير رسميه واعرب عن
امتنان لكل من تضامن مع فينيسيوس من
زملائه وقال انهم تفاجاوا بتصريحات رئيس
الاتحاد الاسباني لكره القدم وانه ما اخذ
الاجراءات اللازمه ضد اللي صار وانه هذا
الموقف خلى فينيسيوس عاجز امام الحكام
وتابع انه بيامل للتواصل الاجراءات حازمه
وفوريه للقضاء على العنصريه وحقيقه وحقيقه
طبعا يعني التطورات حول القضيه بتتسارع
كثير وملحقين على العناوين والاخبار اللي
بتيجي ومن ساعه بس صار في تطورات كثيره
منها انه الشرطه الاسبانيه يحتجزت سبعه
على علاقه باساءات عنصريه ضد فينيسيوس
ثلاثه في فالنسيا واربعه في مدريد وكمان
طلع المدير الفني لنادي ريال مدريد
انه لازم يكون في تصدي للعنصريه او انه
هذه مباراه مو حرب وقال انه فينيسيوس ضحيه
وماله ذنبه انه ما بيقدر يتدرب لانه حزين
بسبب اللي صار واكد انه ما رح يغادر نادي
ريال مدريد لانه بيحب النادي وبحب بلده
ومن التطورات اللافته كمان خلال الساعات
الماضيه انه شركه بومه اللي هي راعي فريق
فالنسيان قدمت كل دعمها لفينيسيوس وحتى
بنك السانتادير او الاسباني الراعي للدوري
الاسباني اعلن دعمه لفينيسيوس ورفضه
للتحيز العنصري وحقيقه اللي صار مع
فينيسيوس واللي تكلم فيها عن العنصريه
اللي بيواجهها بالدوري الاسباني اضاء على
تعليقات جالسين بنسمعها كثير على المنصات
وتحديدا في الفتره الاخيره وخصوصا من
متابعي الكره اللي بيلوموا على اللي بيصير
تحديدا في الكره الاوروبيه او بيقولوا انه
العنصريه اللي بتصير فيها ما بنشوفها في
اي مكان ثاني هذا غير الانتقادات للفيفا
والاتحاد الاوروبي اللي الناس شايفه انهم
ما بيعملوا اللازم لوقت هذه الظاهره تماما
على الاقل يعني في الملاعب وخلال
المباريات لو مو قادرين مثلا يقضوا عليها
تماما في الشوارع وعلى المنصات طيب خلينا
نناقش هذا الموضوع معنا من القاهره
الاعلامي والمحل الرياضي
اسر حسين خلينا نناقش معك الموضوع اليوم
بالتفصيل اهلا فيك معانا يا اسر طيب هل
بتتفق مع وجهه النظر اللي بتقول انه
الدوري الاسباني بالتحديد والدوري
الاوروبي عموما الدوريات الاوروبيه هي
الاكثر عنصريه
اهلا بك يا ساره وسعيد اللي معك مع جمهورك
المحترم بالطبع بعتقد ان انا يعني بوافق
على جزء كبير من اللي بيتقال ان دوري
الاسباني من اكثر الدوريات عنصريه لانه
حتى على مستوى الخمس دوريات الكبرى اللي
هي بتمثل اوروبا او اللي احنا عارفينها
خمس دولارات الكبرى واعتقد ان اسبانيا
يمكن وايطاليا اقلهم في التعامل مع
العنصريه وعندنا مواقع مهمه جدا يا ساره
يمكن في الاسابيع الماضيه كانت في الدوري
الايطالي روميل لوكاكو اللاعب البلجيكي
وهو اسمر البشره كما فينيسيوس تماما وكان
جمهور يوفنتوس بيشتمه او بيقول عليه هتاف
جمعي عنصري واللعب احتفل بتسجيل ضربه جزاء
في ملعب يوفنتوس بانه بس اشار له علامه
الصمت وبالتالي تم طرده بالظبط طرد الضحيه
او معاقبه الضحيه طرده من اللقاء ومنع
جمهور او جزء من مدرج يوفنتوس انه يحضر
مباراه وبعد كده الاتحاد الايطالي يقرر او
او يعني الرجوع في القرار وعدم منع
الجمهور من حضور اللقاء هي نفس الفكره في
مساله فينيسيوس ومساله فالنسيا ومساله
الدوري الاسبانيه ساره هي فكره
الحادثه الحاجه التانيه طبعا من المستجدات
ليش تعتقد انه الموضوع هذه المره تحديدا
وصل لهذه الدرجه يعني شفنا انه رئيس
الدوله تحدث يعني كثير ناس اسماء كبيره
تحدثت
الموضوع بيستمر وما فيش حل جذري ليه ناس
بتتكلم بمنتهى السذاجه او براءه دايما
يعني الفاعل او او العمل الجريمه الكراهيه
دي بانه نعمل ايه لا في حاجات كتير قوي
تعمله بعتقد انه نجاح الحمله هذه المره هو
انه طبعا لولا ده السيلفر رئيس البرازيل
استخدم اهم نمبر وهو الوجود في مجموعه
السبع في الجي 7 في هيروشيما واتكلم مدافع
عن لاعب او مواطن عنده برازيلي بيتعرض
لعنصريه تامه الكلام لازم يكون على
عقوبه بخصم النقاط عقوبه من حرمان الجمهور
من الحضور اللي بيعمل الفعل العنصري ده
وهو مشجع لنادي ساره اهم حاجه تفرق معاه
هو النادي لو حرمته من الحضور او حرمت
الجمهور من من المدرج او حرمت النادي من
جمهور هنا
الحسن ناس كثير كمان خلينا يعني نعطي وجهه
النظر الاخرى ناس كثير جالسين بيقولوا انه
يعني معليش مع هذه كره قدم وفيها تعليقات
من هذا النوع وياما اللعيبه في الملاعب
بيسمعوا كلمات مش ضروري حتى عنصريه كلمات
من نوع اخرى شتائم وما الى ذلك وانه مثلا
دائما بيذكروا ح ادثه اللي هي لاعب
برشلونه داني الفيش لمن لمن رامولو موزه
في الملعب فهو مسكها ووقف واكلها وكمل لعب
يعني فبيقولوا انه يعني خلاص انه شويه
ربوا جلد اسمك يعني
لا طبعا ده طبعا كلام في اتجاه سلبي جدا
في اتجاه قبول امور لا يمكن تكون مقبوله
في القرن الحادي والعشرين لا يمكن ابدا
تقبل العنصريه باي شكل من اشكال سواء
عنصريه بلون البشره سواء عنصريه ضد مثلا
الجنس تجاه مثلا لاعبات كره القدم تجاه اي
شيء لابد من عدم قبوله كمان الكلام على هل
حقيقي هل هل هل في الموقف اللي حصل ده في
حد دفع الثمن حتى الان بشكل رسمي الضحيه
وهو فينيسيوس تعرض للطرد قرار مناسب جدا
النهارده
اعفى سته من الحكام اللي موجودين في غرفه
الفار يا ساره من التحكيم وراحلهم عن
التحكيم في الدوري الاسباني لكن في
النهايه السؤال هل هيرفع الطرد اللي اخذه
فينيسيوس بشكل ظالم والحقيقه الجاني
الحقيقه وهو جدوره وقرار كمان اتحاد
الحكام في اسبانيا راجع لانه لم يقدم او
كان في تلاعب باللقطات في غرفه الفار بانه
ارسلوا اللقطات غير الصحيحه للحكم ريكاردو
بانه دافنيسيوس هو اللاعب وفي الحقيقه ان
اللاعب هو اللي كان تم بخنقه في لقطات
سابقه فالتلاعب باللقطات في غرفه الفار
ادى الى اعفاء سته من الحكام الفار في
المباراه وعلى راسهم طبعا
مسؤول عن غرفه الفار فبالتالي ده قرار مهم
ولكن هل هترفع عقوبه الطرد عن اللاعب اللي
هو في الاساس هو الضحيه على العموم احنا
هنشوف لانه واضح ان الموضوع يعني بيتطور
وواضح انه خلاص اللعيبه ويمكن الفرق كمان
خلاص ملوا من هذا الموضوع فنحن بنشكرك على
هذه المداخله كان معنا
حتى كمان
الرياضي اسر حسين طبعا اكيد حتى المشجعين
طبعا